pour l'instant je vous propose après ce
deuxième tour donc des élections
législatives ce dimanche 19 juin je le
rappelle de faire un point sur les
candidats qui ont été élus donc députés
dans le département et c'est avec vous
c'est lié à 400 go bonsoir ça alors est
ce qu'on peut faire un tour des
résultats dans les deux circonscriptions
avec vous oui alors les résultats ont vu
naître quelques surprises on s'attendait
plus ou moins un carton plat pour la
majorité présidentielle à l'issue du
premier tour donc dans les yvelines et
finalement score final guide sur 12 de
circonscription était remporté par
ensemble et on va commencer par ce
chiffre 71 faire que le 40% pour
béatrice piron réélu pour un second
mandat dans la troisième circonscription
des yvelines c'est elle qui obtient le
meilleur score pour ensemble elle était
face à luis brody de la nuque baisse
d'autres députés ensemble ont largement
été réélu comme jean noël barrot avec 64
père qui le 27 % des voix on peut citer
aussi quatre femmes qui ont été
également un très confortablement réélue
en totalisant à chaque fois plus de 60%
des voix il ya elle est productive et
natalia pouzy réf aurore bergé et marie
le bec alors avec un peu moins de 60% le
des voix bruno myle yen est également
réélu dans la 9e circonscription des
yvelines il était opposé aux seuls
candidats fn au second tour laurent
maurin et donc si on reste un peu dans
la majorité présidentielle il ya quand
même trois nouvelles têtes plus ou moins
connu un qui rentre ou font leur retour
en tout cas à l'assemblée nationale oui
et on va commencer par le député le plus
jeune des douze circonscriptions un an
juste il alors il me semble que ce
monsieur rodwell première
circonscription ces jardins réviser les
cfc charles renaud elle a 25 ans il
devient le nouveau député de la première
circonscription
autre petit nouveau
karl olive maire de poissy il rentre à
l'assemblée en devenant un député de la
12e circonscription est une
particularité nadia et qui retrouve son
siège au sein de l'hémicycle autrefois
aux députés dans la 11e elle revient
dans la septième en battant michel
christophoul avec 55,64 % des voix mais
on finit sa vie oui on sait ça ce taux
peut être avec elle les résultats des
candidats finalement les deux candidats
de la nouvelle coalition dont une
épaisse oui donc la gauche a gagné deux
députés dans les yvelines williams
martinez dans la 11e circonscription
tout juste élu avec environ une centaine
de voix d' avance et dans la 8e
circonscription et territoires de mantes
la jolie c'est benjamin lucas merci
beaucoup c'est la gamme 100 go pour ces
informations